foreign
terminology language and the
international legitimacy this is not
contested the Palestinian people live
under a belonged Israeli military
occupation
I believe the Biden Administration
realizes today the power of narrative
they are very very aware of the impact
of this course nowadays specifically the
framing of the conflict so we see the
medical administration focusing on the
role of liberal peace building agenda
when it comes to the passing Israeli
context a process that had embedded a
deeply unjust and unequitable Status Quo
to just try to interpret why this person
did not or avoid that refrain from
saying military occupation and speaking
about Israel well basically in the 21st
century it would be absurd just absurd
for any conscious person to accept the
existence of any military occupation and
apartheid against any peoples
[Music]
America offering money to the
Palestinians is nice we appreciate
Prosperity we appreciate economic
normalization however this shall not
bring a solution to the Middle East so
the American lip service and the ATM
machine approach of sustaining honorua
or sustaining the status quo of the PA
for example while at the same time
tolerating settlements expansions that's
the retailer annexation apartheid
application of all kinds of
discriminatory laws
[Applause]
here
[Music]
the U.S Administration needs to realize
that it is not a matter of you know
other periodic flare-ups and ceasefire
this is about ethnic cleansing of the
Palestinian people this is about
apartheid annexation settler colonialism
however it all comes Under the Umbrella
of 73 years of Injustice under the
Israeli military occupation
foreign